childish gambino and Rianna's mystery
project guava island is here and we are
having a full meltdown a full meltdown
so Hana Glover reportedly released a
sneak peek of his super secret
collaboration at Ferris Festival in New
Zealand over the weekend and naturally
once the internet got a hold of it
there's been a full-on investigation to
figure out the beat we need to know if
we're gonna investigate okay so let's
set the scene Wow yeah that's at the
scene so the trailer kind of kicks off
with him and Rihanna clearly
boyfriend/girlfriend yeah it seems like
they're they're an item because Rihanna
walks in while Donald Glover is playing
this mystery song and she pretty much
calls him out and says well you didn't
ruin that part that was beautiful that
was perfection yeah
he said that's funny that's what my
other girlfriend said and then she kind
of hits them
yeah like playfully exactly yeah and of
course we see they're in a beautiful
tropical island so of course we're
thinking that that's guava island yeah
yeah but great chemistry love it I love
Rihanna as an actress I'm really excited
about this exactly and reports are
saying it's some kind of action crime
movie we get a little hit so that
there's like a bag over somebody said at
one point I don't know what's gonna go
down in this but other people think that
it's a music video in a video and if you
know Donald Glover he's someone that
kind of emerges both worlds his childish
can't be you know I saw that what this
is America and we know that the director
is gonna be someone that we done yeah
here a Mirai and he's a director for a
lot of Donald's things in Atlanta and
and this is America and he's never
directed a feature film before he's done
a TV movie and not to say he's not ready
for a feature film because he absolutely
100 is that I want that but it just
gives me the hunch that it could it's
it's a music project yeah it makes me
feel the same way I am excited to hear
that it's a rumor that Black Panthers
leticia right would it would appear in
the dark she's mentioned in that trailer
and I love it and we also asked Rihanna
about it
Childish Gambino's said I'm here I'm
gonna perform
we saw some photos from Cuba are you
guys what is guava island I
not speak on that that is for him to
speak on okay I will leave it at that
but it was an exciting experience of
course we know rihanna is keeping a
tight lip because this is a donald
glover childish gambino project but we
have a hunch that this is his last
project before he retires his rap name
for good what do you guys think what do
you think I think don't you think if it
was a movie she would have at least said
something like she was so tight-lipped
to the point where I'm like this is
something that he really wanted to keep
under wraps for some reason and we know
that Donald Glover is retiring his rap
name he confirmed at the 2018 Grammys
that he was still working on stuff but
he's definitely gonna be done I'm making
another project right now just you know
to make and but I like endings and I
think they're important to progress okay
so could guava island be the final
project he was referring to I feel like
he gave us some foreshadowing I think so
too because this was in January it's now
November like the timeline kind of adds
up that that would have been what he was
working on and he also in his debut
album there was a line that everyone is
referring back to about Rihanna he said
this now I've got some but I want it all
I won't stop until Rihanna gives my call
which wouldn't that be like the perfect
full circle thing that he would and he
would definitely go and do that he'd be
like what and since I started this way I
gotta end
yes Rihanna he's very calculated which
is why he's such a creative genius so I
really do feel like this is his last
call we want to know what you guys think
Oliver social I think we solved it just
FYI but we think well violin is some
sort of music project we're on the same
page and I want to know what would you
guys rather see do you want it to be a
music project do you want it to be a
straight-up movie do you think it's
gonna be some kind of blend which is
what I'm gonna yeah I'm kind of leaning
toward that as well I really hope it's
something music relating with a great
visual like this is America from horse
we know Donald's gonna give a message
I'm gonna stop talking okay talk to me
over at Kourtney underscore teza know
and I'm at ash Crossin until next time
you got you covered for your pop culture
fix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]